(intro)
Depression and mental illnesses are different for everyone
With this list we are not trying to generalize
Instead we've compiled certain things individuals with Depression have disclosed they struggle with
Can you relate to any of these or know someone who might?
Here are 11 things people with depression would like their family and friends to understand
One. it's not as simple as eating healthier and exercising more
While we appreciate you trying to help us the underlying condition isn't always solved that easily; it still feels like your feelings
Are being invalidated if things aren't phrased carefully.
Two - it's not always easy to understand why things are this way.
Depression doesn't always have a specific trigger. It just happens. It's more complicated than just feeling sad because we got a bad grade
Assumptions like this are diminishing our experiences
Sometimes there's no emotion sometimes there's too much
It often isn't very clear why either.
We'd like to understand it better ourselves but depression can make you feel a wide variety of confusing things.
Four - It's not that we're not trying hard enough
No one wants to have depression
Telling us this when we are trying our hardest is dismissing our struggle. It's hurtful
5 - we can't just snap out of it. If it was possible to simply get over it
We would have done it a long time ago
It's not a mood that you can come out of when you're done
6-  we don't want to hurt others.
We hate to feel like an annoyance because of our illness
We don't want to cause the people around us pain because of what we're going through
7 - we feel like a burden
Reassurance might not magically solve our depression, but it can help us open up the better feelings
We need validation that were not an annoyance to be able to relax around you
We appreciate your efforts
We notice you trying to help us and we are very grateful
Reaching out to us is already a ray of light
but please remember
9 - we aren't asking you to fix us
Being there for us and showing that you're trying to understand is enough
We aren't asking you for solutions and as well intended as it may be sometimes we just need someone who will listen
10 - it's not your fault
There's no one single factor that causes depression. It's an illness
Certain things can contribute to it, but it's nobody's fault
11 - we appreciate you asking what you can do for us.
Sometimes it's not easy for us to pinpoint what we need. That's why some people might find it easier if you ask more specific
Things like can I get you some tea maybe?
Want to go for a walk ? it might not seem like much
But it might help a person realize what they really need at the moment
Do you have any other things you wish your friends and family would understand?